The nation just got its report card, and
the marks aren't great. NAEP is the only
test that allows you to compare scores
across states, demographics, and over time,
and as the best indicator of our
students performance, it's often called
The Nation's Report Card. Recently
released 2017 NAEP results show that
fourth and eighth graders' math and
reading scores were mostly flat. That
doesn't sound so bad, but after a peak in
2013, reading and math scores dipped in
2015... for the first time ever... after two
decades of steady gains. The latest
results confirmed that our progress has
stalled. But the details add to the story.
The scores of the poorest performing
students were lower this year than in
2015, and high performers' scores were even
higher, meaning the gap between them is
growing, leaving our most challenged
students further behind. Though
concerning, these scores can't tell us
why performance is flat, and anyone using
them to do so is selling something. But
like any report card,
NAEP can serve as a wake-up call that
there's plenty of hard work ahead.
What do you think about the latest round of scores on The Nation's Report Card? Let
us know in your comments. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.